hi and welcome to crash course
cryosphere I'm Simon I'm Tom and I'm
gonna let Tom explain what he's doing
this week because you're not gonna see
very much of me
thank you very much Simon yes this week
we're looking at a bit more of mass
balance and then linking mass balance to
climate change don't worry there will be
more of me in the future great using the
concepts of accumulation ablation we can
now look at where ice is lost and where
ice is gained in the Glacial system the
first thing that we must address is
where the glacier will be fit so this
will be where the accumulation outweighs
the ablation over a whole year so
there's a net gain of ice this is where
the ice and snow is coming into the
system essentially and this is known as
the accumulation zone in a simple valley
glacier the accumulation zone is nearly
always at the head of the glacier this
is their area up in the mountains the
two basic reasons for this are the
mountains are higher and therefore
colder and also you get more
precipitation there you get more
precipitation to orographic rainfall ie
the type of rain that you get when an
air mass rises over there
mountains of course there are other
factors in the high mountains that can
contribute to accumulation particularly
regions like the Karakoram or the
Himalayas get a lot of snow avalanching
off very steep valley walls onto the
head of the glacier and this contributes
to it being an accumulation zone it
doesn't just have to be delivered
through snow the net gain of ice we've
just described doesn't mean that the
accumulations they will just keep on
growing and she's got a huge ball of ice
up in the mountains the accumulation in
at the perfect system will always be
balanced by the outflow of ice through
transport processes however these
perfect systems are very rare in reality
and particularly in today's changing
climate other things happen to
demonstrate the anatomy of a typical
glacier tom is now going to show you
something he's been working on for quite
awhile it's a bit of a pet project and
you might be able to tell he's quite
excited to share it with you here we
have our pet Glacia this pet Glacia is
gary the glacier and he's in fact an
Icelandic glacial this is partly because
the way we've modelled him is with this
kind of Plateau
very flat type melting around him which
is mostly due to the fact that the foam
sheets came in that shape and it was
easier to carve it that way but also
because I spent a lot of my time in Nice
and in terms of Glacial research I'm a
big fan of their glaciers so we have the
glacier Gary the glacier sitting in the
valley here the first thing I'll point
out to you is the accumulation zone so
in this case the accumulation zone
probably ending at about here it's at
this point where you stop seeing snow
and ice on the tops and the in
particularly the sides of the valley
indicating that the summer ablation is
starting to remove most snow material
from this point downwards above here we
have the head wall of the glacier well
the head wall of the valley I should say
where the glacier has carved into the
back and beneath there you can't see it
cuz it's beneath the glacier right now
we have an over deepening where the ice
has carved down off the back wall of the
mountain and come up again and up over
the lip where it flows down Valley we
can see this point where he comes flows
over the lip by these crevasses which
are on the top surface here so that's
the accumulation area of Gary
but his ablation area is further down
here we have as the ice comes down out
of the mountains it's losing altitude
and moving into air that has a mean
annual air temperature of above North
degrees Celsius essentially this is what
the ablation area is as it moves down
out of the valley its hits a breaking
slope as it comes out of the mountains
and onto the flat plane it spreads out
this is often called a Piemonte type low
glacier or Piedmont depending on if you
can pronounce French or not which I
certainly can't the reason why I spread
out in a lobe is because as it comes
down off the valley slope it goes from
moving under its own mass down the slope
to being on a flat plane so the only
movement is taking place primarily due
to the weight of the ice coming in
behind and remember ice is a plastic
solid so as it comes in it will deform
and push and spreads out in this flat
lobe type shape usually given lots of
crevasses around the front due to
expansion and brittle failure we also
have more curved asses as it comes over
this break and slope again due to
brittle failure now down in front of
Gary we have his progression landscapes
this is the landscape in front of the
glacier it's no longer covered by ice
but it is still strongly affected by
glacial processes and
shapes and forms that you see in the
landscape there are due to the glacial
processes that took place on top of it
immediately in front of the glacier we
have Marines Marine can mean several
things in several different languages
but fundamentally here moraine is a
continuous body of sediment that has
been pushed up and shaped into a
sculpture by the glacier in this case
these are terminal Marines say follow
the shape of the nose of the glacier as
it spreads out into the valley below in
these Marines we have small gaps in them
and this is where the progression
alluvial rivers have cut through the
Marines and wound their way out across
the valley floor and finally in our
particular landscape that we have here
we have some drumlins now jolin's are
supposed to be my favourite land form
because that's why I did my PhD thesis
on
but once you've counted 32,000 of them
the lovers lost a little bit the Germans
here are aligned where the glacier would
have been flowing so they spread out
from the lobe so that was Gary the
glacier I hope you enjoyed your time
with him I certainly have and let's get
on with the rest of the episode as we
descend down the glacier in altitude
ablation processes will become more
important we start to lose more ice than
we're gaining from accumulation the
point to which we cross over from this
accumulation to ablation zone is known
as the equilibrium line altitude this
equilibrium line altitude or ela is a
very important concept that we had to
come across a lot in future episodes
particularly in relation to changing
climate and the cryosphere as with the
accumulation zone not just piling up ice
in the ablation zone is not just melting
away to nothing instead ice is flowing
into the ablation zone from the
accumulation zone and replacing the ice
that is lost to look at these processes
on a larger scale the glazing mass
balance as opposed to the specific mass
balance at a point is the balance of the
ice mass being gained in the
accumulation zone and the ice being lost
in the ablation zone below the ELA the
precise cycle is determined by the local
climactic regime so this could be a
whole series of factors ranging from
very local effects as to what side of
the mountain you're on for up to
regional climate and global climate
changes in our simple model of a stable
perfect glacier system the amount of ice
accumulated is exactly the same as the
amount of ice moved downstream beneath
the ELA and exactly the same as the
amount of ice removed through ablation
below the yearling that's the stable
perfect glacial system
in this episode we've talked about how
we view information changing spatially
such as temperature but the way that we
look at the law is in the only way that
the world can be viewed and we have some
examples of a different viewpoint here
so what are these well these are
replicas of some original maps that are
held in the National Museum in Greenland
and they were make they were made by
East Greenlandic people they were
collected in the 1880s now perhaps if I
just hold one up slightly you can see
there are all these kind of ridges and
maybe it's not obvious what it is but
actually it's a map of an island chain
and a series of coastlines so if we have
a look at the thing you've got here what
we have is a map of the sort that we
know the top-down view it's got the
contour lines and various things marked
on it and you can see how both of these
relate to those island chains so for
every lump and bump there's an island or
a an inlet that it relates to and it's
not linear in space so some of these
islands are much further apart on our
map than there are this but these were
very successful use for navigation so
they just looked at the world spatially
in a totally different way absolutely
and way we think about the world is
completely shifted because nowadays
we've got the earth on our desktop
pretty much
Google Maps satellite imagery has
totally shifted the way we do things so
how often do you go oh I need to get get
somewhere I'll just plug in the
directions and you get this top-down map
and it's how we think of the world it
kind of affects the way you think as
well as the way you live your life it's
a very empirical way of viewing things
like distance experiential it is and
they're designed to be tactile so
they're very much expected to be
something that you feel and you use that
as your input sense if you like which
obviously a 2d map like we have isn't
going to get you very far and these of
course surprisingly modern these are
from the late 19th century that's right
they were collected in the 1880s from
Eastern Greenland so people might think
that it might incorrectly think that
it's a primitive way it's just a
different way yeah absolutely consider
these people navigates considerably
better than Westerners did for a very
long time
maybe we should've used in these maps
well perhaps I think like you say it's
just a different way but if you think
about as Westerners with all of our
advances prior to what the 1960s aerial
photography hadn't really arrived in
most people's world so for most people
it wasn't a top-down view you would
remember the things that you saw around
you will be back in the archives next
week with what I can honestly say is the
box of rocks with the most interesting
story I've ever heard in my life now
though tom is talking about glaciers
that grow and perhaps more relevantly
shrink in the previous section we
considered the perfect lacier that isn't
growing or shrinking but one of the
reasons why we're so interested in
glaciers today and Glaciology in general
this was in a changing climate that
isn't the case so what happens the mass
balance of iglasia under a changing
climate why is the climate changing
again Simon never here Tom the real
scientists are here so a succinctness of
climate change would be changes in the
concentrations of chemicals in the
atmosphere which are radiatively active
at long or thermal wavelengths changing
the energy balance of the earth such
that more energy is absorbed by the
Earth from the Sun than the earth
re-emits into space this change in the
energy balance then increases the total
energy the earth system raising the
planets temperature and changing weather
and climate back to the gravel monkey he
is useful sometimes if the climate
changes so as to increase ablation for
example by increasing the temperature
higher up in that in altitude and
therefore losing more ice that way or by
reducing accumulation by changes in snow
for patterns reduce the amount of snow
going in then we see a net loss in ice
the mass balance has changed the ELA
shifts and the Glacial system is now in
negative mass balance of course the
converse can also be true and if you see
increased snowfall patterns in your
accumulation area then your ela will
move downstream and therefore you get an
advancing Galatia
however for the majority of glacis at
the moment we're seeing a loss of mass
the primary way that we can visualize
the impact of climate change on the mass
balance of a glacier is by considering
the ELA and the
accumulation ablation zones that we
talked about earlier is the change in
the relative sizes between the
accumulation and ablation zones that
dictates whether or not a glacier will
be advancing or retreating in the case
of a glacier that is in a negative mass
balance state the ice will continue to
be lost from the ablation zone until
that ablation zone has moved far enough
up the system that it is no longer
significantly larger than the
accumulation zone and therefore at this
point the glacier is now once more in
balance
and a net gain loss is once more zero
the key methods for monitoring glacier
mass balance change are the direct
method hydrological geodetic methods and
gravimetric methods direct measurement
is done via accumulation and ablation
stakes this is where you literally go to
the glacier hammer a stake into the
surface and then come back regularly to
measure the change neither accumulation
or ablation obviously this is a pretty
old-school method and generates only
point-source datasets which would then
have to be interpolated from the
hydrological method is based upon the
concept that the annual mass balance of
a glacier represents a change in the
hydrological state of an entire
catchment therefore if you know all the
inputs and outputs of this catchment you
can calculate the net mass balance
however this is a pretty hand wavy
method because it's very difficult to
actually know what all the inputs and
outputs are in the geodetic method you
use repeat satellite or aerial
photography that's very similar to the
sort of stereo photography that was done
in World War two for reconnaissance to
calculate changes in volume this change
in volume can then be converted to mass
with assumptions about the average
density of snow and ice obviously you're
making an assumption here and that's
always a dangerous thing to do in
science and therefore whilst this method
is very good for fairly rapid quick and
repeat mass balance monitoring there are
accuracy problems and finally we have
the gravimetric method this is mono my
personal favorite methods mostly because
it's so cool in the government trick
method we're actually directly
monitoring the gravitational field of
the earth and the changes in it this is
done via a pair of satellites called the
grace satellites they're flying in
low-earth orbit the reason why this
method so cool is that for the first
time we're really directly monitoring
the change in mass all of the other
methods we use in volume and then in
extrapolating from that we're
interpolating from point measurements
here is a direct measurement continuous
measurement of changes in the earth
I smash and that's both very useful and
quite cool in this episode we've covered
the equilibrium line altitude or ela
this is a really important concept and
it's an imaginary line where the
ablation and accumulation zones meet
that the ELA is important when
determining if a glacier is advancing or
retreating that is if it's getting
bigger or smaller and that iglesias
response to climate change depends on
the balance between increased ablation
due to higher temperatures and changes
in accumulation due to shifts in
precipitation patterns thank you for
watching crash course cryosphere if you
have any questions about the material
we've talked about in this episode then
down there in the comments Tom and I
will be battling it out trying to clear
up any misconceptions for two hours
after this video is released and if
you'd like to take your understanding
further on any of the subjects covered
there are links to further reading in
the description we'd like to thank as
ever all of these lovely people for
helping make this series possible and in
particular the recover project at x2
University for funding us and to the
Scott Polar Research Institute at the
University of Cambridge for being so
accommodating to us we'll see you next
week
you